hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about omega-6 fatty acids and
inflammation now as you may not know or
you may now omega-6 basically will
increase your inflammation omega-3 fatty
acids decrease inflammation or
anti-inflammatory okay now in America
the ratio is 1 to 20 omega-6 in other
words people consume way way more
omega-6 then omega-3 okay ideally it
needs to be 1 to 1 and what does that
mean I mean it tells us what we need to
be eating because look at these are the
omega-6 fatty acid foods poultry nuts
vegetable oils like corn oil grains flax
oil pumpkin seed oil canola soybean
cottonseed sunflower
but you know some of these here do have
Omega 3 but they're heavier on the
omega-6 fatty acid so these will tend to
create more inflammation if you don't
have these right here fish oils cod
liver oil
sardines fish anchovies grass-fed eggs
aggressive beef beef things like that or
even some dairy so basically we want to
balance these out now the problem is
like flax oil for example can convert to
omega-3 DHA which is a certain type of
essential fatty acid but it only
converts in smaller amounts so one thing
is animal food or fish has a lot more
bioavailable omega-3 DHA and EPA those
are very specific types of fats then
these other ones because the other ones
have to convert so it's harder for your
body to convert like grains or even flax
oil or sunflower to the thing that you
really need so again here's this like
something that you want to if you want
to know what would be the ideal food
that we need you know just look at
what's out there and what's absorbed and
apparently our diets our bodies were
designed to consume some of these foods
right here now the problem with
soils especially if you buy it at
probably these that you know at the
local grocery store you're going to get
in bulk you're going to get a low
quality fish oil it's probably going to
be Rance it's probably worse than not
have anything at all so I would not
recommend consuming inexpensive fish oil
what I do recommend is going out
investing more in something like virgin
cod liver oil something very raw and
fresh it is more expensive but it really
works
now sardines are really good you can
even get the benefits from the can but
see the larger fish like shark or
swordfish are higher in mercury but it
just so happens that a lot of these fish
and even the collar oil are very very
high in a trace mineral called selenium
and the relationship between selenium
and mercury is interesting mercury tends
to inactivate the enzymes that have
selenium that make them up so that's why
you want to consume some of these higher
quality fish oils especially the cod
liver oil to get more selenium to be
able to do dismantle any mercury that's
in there so basically more selenium the
less mercury effect that you'll have on
the body and it just so happens the
other thing that has a lot of selenium
is wheatgrass juice especially the kamut
I added in the recent when I added a
little kamut in there which is 25% kamut
which is a type of wheatgrass which is
loaded with selenium which is a really
good mineral to support the enzymes that
have detoxifying powers on the liver if
you have inflammation in your body you
just need to start increasing the
omega-3 fatty acids go with quality I
suggest you get the cod liver oil get
the wild-caught cod liver oil that was
probably the best but you can also do
some of these other things too and make
sure that we balance these two right
here all right thanks for watching hey
guys thank you so much for watching
please
like the subscribe button and I will see
you in the next video